what do you look for in a man or
significant other okay what I look for
in a man is kind eyes and what I mean by
that is just some one of respects you
and respects just all human life in
general
are there ever any deal-breakers there's
just so many of them but I guess just
someone who is just kind of too
self-absorbed or like cares too much
about I mean they think it's important
to care about your physical appearance
to an extent but when you're to over
absorbed with our or you think that's
like the only thing that matters it's
definitely eternal
that is a really interesting question I
actually lost my husband in September so
I honestly
right now I'm not looking for anything
but if I were gonna be looking for
someone I guess ever in the future it'd
be someone that makes me laugh and that
understands that life is to be lived in
the moment and that it's an adventure
every day and that you can find fun and
work enos in the ordinary and obviously
someone that has some ambition and some
Drive and we
potentially a good father figure to my
kids what was it about your husband
would you choose him Mike was my high
school sweetheart we met when we were 15
and I fell in love with the fact that he
was funny
easygoing and we just clicked he got my
humor and then we were apart for 10
years and when we met later in our late
20s
well methacel I actually early toys I
had a daughter and Mike instantly fell
in love with her he had always said and
maintained that even if I had said I
didn't want to get married he would
probably have pursued me even harder
just because he fell in love with Olivia
and I think that's one of the most
attractive things is to be able to
look into someone else's child's eyes
and say you're mine and I love you
well I think in an uncertain world
you're looking for constancy sincerity
authenticity accountability trust love
and respect humor
passion tall ordering all the things
actually we lack in the current
administration I would say if you can
think of the antithesis of chunk that's
probably the perfect man I look for
someone if I can look into their eyes
and see something similar to my own soul
like I was looking in the mirror someone
who's familiar and someone who can keep
up with me yeah and then um yeah that's
it you just got to be free you can't you
can't have your own role as your minds
your own prison and the world is so big
you got to be free with me that's it
I mean looks are nice bollocks are gonna
fade you know yeah
Oh another one is I look for how the way
that they treat other people especially
when nobody's looking tall good sense of
humor really nerdy is how I describe it
is like basically the guys I hang out
with where I hang out with a lot like
nerdy or guys or they're very into video
games and like their TV shows
so you all really yeah this is my
beautiful significant other so what is
it about her that even so she meets all
those things that you just said what
sets her apart from someone else who
might have also that she's the most
beautiful spirit inside and out and
empathetic and when she told me she's
super into empathetic and caring to
others and has like thoughtfulness and
awareness and insight about her own life
and about those around her is what sets
her apart isn't a one in a million it
was somebody who was fun adventurous and
a little on the conscious mind that's
pretty much all I did when I left work
and God now I regret it I like the
cockiness but it's nice that it kind of
calms down when you're married for a
while
I think some important factors would be
like you have to develop trust so
somebody that you're comfortable around
and that they're responsible and usually
share around the same interests as you
now it's just like
any deal-breakers um I mean I feel like
if you fall in love with a person you're
gonna accept them for who they are
whether you know even if they see falls
in themselves that that's kind of like
things that you'll maybe see the beauty
in them so honestly just someone who
loves unconditionally with
any-anything stopping them ahold of you
holding them back and someone who loves
me for my flaws and just for Who I am
days bad days nothing materialistic does
pure emotional someone who's as raw as I
like I love unconditionally I want the
same
are you in relationship yes you are and
you fight you have that would you say um
almost you know I almost he has to get
hurt and he's probably the only person
used to love me as much as a man
IVA promised obviously I should be
physically attracted to them but as to
be emotionally attracted to them have
you ever been in a relationship with
someone who had all those things yeah
was there something unique about them
that made you choose them over someone
else who might have also had the same
tree
I have autoimmune liver disease which is
not caused by drugs or anything bad it's
just random and bad luck and he accepted
that I don't think very many people
would stick around for someone who's in
the hospital like every five seconds my
liver is 80% dead and I've got about two
years to live unless my doctor which is
the only doctor that has ever cured my
disease can cure it so he was willing to
stick around for that but I had
forgotten that sometimes when you're
leaning on someone all the time you
forget that sometimes they need to be
you need to be the strong one too
I look for that he's a follower of
Christ and that he loves the Lord
and he's a gentleman and southern Texas
boy country boy if I was looking for a
man which I'm not the Lord has given to
me contentedness with my singleness but
if I was looking for me and the number
one quality would be someone who loves
the Lord Jesus Christ and number two a
good sense of humor and had
characteristics of the Lord of Jesus a
good kind man with a servant's heart
that's what I would be looking for but
I'm contented with my singleness which
it says in God's Word as a gift from him
so that's that I definitely like to be
with creative people I myself am an
artist so I need someone who understands
that process of it's not just a
glamorous lifestyle of being you know
creative artistic person it's like a lot
of like just sitting in like a with a
room with one light and just drawing for
hours and that's important so I need
somebody who understands that so
creativity self-awareness I like
somebody who's a little geeky and not
afraid to be geeky I just like seeing
somebody get excited and passionate
about something and not being a
self-conscious like oh is that cool what
do you look for in a man or significant
other gave us a procore enormous oh and
that's what I saw I saw special
you say sure I do me stage I'm also a
novelist with noble-hearted didn't it
hurt it getting awesome like I don't
know who'd say affectionate affection
with yeah well this hunk right here I'm
gonna have engaged to him
um but someone who is compatible with me
and full of life and caring and
compassionate and creative and
attractive of course and hardworking and
dedicated loyal yeah Dawson cacif all
questions
was there something unique about him
that made me choose him over someone
else who might have had those same
qualities I think just his personality
and how when I met him I instantly felt
comfortable with him and he could make
me laugh and
[Music]
what do you look for in a man or a
significant other a cute but no I'm just
kidding
I look for somebody who's really really
fun because you can use Beautiful's you
want to be but if you're not really
really fun then who cares and a cute
butt
[Laughter]
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I've gained so far and maybe
ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you